hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the super bed
rapid and Blitz currently being played
in Poland Magnus Carlsen has returned to
the board and even though he is no
longer World classical Champion that
honor now belongs to ding lyron uh he is
the world rapid Champion still and here
he will be facing raslavoit a very
strong Polish Grandmaster and
interestingly he will choose uh an
opening that is the Polish defense
you'll see what I mean by this this is
D4 B5 and it's uh well it's it's very
interesting especially for Rapid since
they will be playing first three days of
Blitz and then uh three days of Blitz
and then uh sorry three days of rabbit
and then two days of Blitz uh three
rapid games per day and then uh when the
blood section come as uh it will be nine
games per day so 18 games of Blitz in
total so we're gonna have five days of
incredible chess so let's check this out
and let's see how Magnus fared with this
uh weird idea of playing the Polish
opening so here rather slav opens with
Ponte D4 and the mag strikes with Pawn
to B5 as we've already discussed with
Pawn to E4 and Bishop to B7 so pretty
standard stuff booing after the E4 Pawn
with Bishop to D3 defending and now just
Knight to F6 if you wanted you could
even try to pull off the uh the F5 here
but it doesn't work because of the same
idea why it doesn't work in the famous
Greco game here for those of you who
maybe don't know the famous Greco game
after Bishop captures and G2 you don't
really have anything because Queen H5
check G6 captures and now after Knight
to F6 white just happily captures the
pawn and H7 sacrifices the queen and
after the queen is captured Knight to G6
is checkmate so uh for those of you who
maybe don't know the famous Greco
miniature it is also possible to
get it from this position yeah so Knight
to F6 puts more pressure on the E4 pawn
and the white of course will defend
Knight to D2 uh and pawn to C5 and now
it is already as of move forward that we
have a completely new game so C3 and now
C captures and d4c campus we have pawned
the E6 and Knight G2 F3 just continuing
development Knight to C6 and now we have
castles we have Pawn to A6 now defending
the B5 Pawn the the white maybe could
have decided to capture it but you know
that if Magnus is offering it it doesn't
really do anything Rook to E1 and now
Bishop to E7 we have a pawn to D5 not
allowing Magnus the castle uh e Captain
D5 and now of course spawn to E5 and
here rosloft says you will not be
castling very early at this game so
Knight stage five and now Knights the B3
saying that if you Castle now I'm gonna
play G4 and trap your knight so Magnus
has to play G6 G6 is played uh Bishop to
H6 again eradic uh stops castling with
Rook to G8 and now he just moves the
bishop back Bishop to E3 as Magnus can
no longer Castle we have Knights the G7
Knight to C5 and here you should
actually consider Bishop captures on C5
this Knight is just a monster here but
Magnus decides to go for king queen to
C7 uh or okay you uh like I said you you
could capture let's say captors capture
but then the problem is Bishop to D6 how
do you avoid this it's a a very nasty
move to meet like in a knight E6 Bishop
to D6 and this King will be stuck here
for very long even if you get the Knight
all the way to F5 probably Bishop just
captures Knight and this bishop remains
here for a very long time uh so instead
Magnus goes for Queen to C7 Rook to C1
now nicely aligning The Rook with the
queen and the C file and not Knight the
E6 with Knight captures on B7 opening up
the uh the C file for The Rook with
Queen capture some B7 and now just
Bishop back to F1 now the queen is
attacking the D5 pawn and Magnus has to
defend it but first he will improve the
position of his Bishop Rogue before
attacks the The Rook uh Bush before
attacks The Rook Rook to E2 and now
Knights the E7 of course now the pawn is
nicely defended uh and Rook eat the C2
uh claiming the the C file for himself
and now a Magnus could consider
something like Rook to see it to try and
trade off everything but he goes Knight
to the F5 first puts pressure on the
dark Square Bishop here and now just the
bishop to G5 uh with Bishop D7 offering
a trade of Bishops uh and now Bishop to
F6
um really wants to get this Pawn all the
way to F6 with Knight G2 F7 now comes
Queen to D3 nicely developing the queen
with Bishop captures on F6 Pawn captures
attacks the Knight and not just Knight
the H5 and here
uh Queen to C3 and uh Magnus has to be
very very careful here if the knight uh
moves uh for whatever reason from E6
then Queen to C8 will lead to Checkmate
because after everything gets traded the
final Rook will deliver mate so you
can't really move the Knight away from
E6 and you don't really want to I mean
it also opens up the E file even if even
if you don't have Checkmate so Rook the
d8 here uh and pawn to A3 with Queen to
B8 and now comes Pawn to G3 not allowing
anything to to come to F4 uh Pawn to G5
by Magnus and now Rook the E1 we have
Pawn to G4 further advancing his G Pawn
now comes Knight to D4 attacking the
Knight but also with ideas of maybe
Knight to F5 would be very nice so look
to G5 by Magnus and now Bishop all the
way to D3 uh putting pressure on the H7
Pawn we have rooked the E5 attacking the
The Rook here and just Knight the F5 and
here what can Magnus do uh well best
would be to play the form this would
offer the most resistance but Magnus
went for Rook captures anyone with check
Queen captures and now Knight characters
on F6 he finally gets rid of the F6
spawn and it seems that now everything
is perfectly fine but there is a problem
and that is that arousal now plays with
engine mic Precision he plays Queen to
B4 threatens Checkmate on E7 uh we have
Pawn to D6 and now Queen to C3 puts the
puts pressure on the Knight on F6 uh
Knight the D7 Knight the G8 uh should
hold a little bit better but it's rapid
chess both of them are very long time
with the Knight the D7 Queen to h8 with
check and now Knight D to f8 blocking
um and now how do you sorry now the
detail f8 blocking Queen to F6
threatening Checkmate and here Magnus
played Knight to G6 the knight from G6
guards D7 square but the position is
completely winning for uh rather slav so
feel free to pause the video and to win
the game against the rapid world
champion Magnus Carlsen uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
wild idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook to E2
and now there is no escape from Rook
captures on E6 but pretty much every
other move uh wins as well so
congratulations to everyone who found
that Magnus played Queen to C7 to try
and get more pieces into the defense but
now Knight to G7 with check and it was
in this position unmove uh 38 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is even if you you don't
have to play this you could also play
Rook captures on E6 with check it also
leads to a beautiful win let's take King
f8 now you just play Queen to F6 with
the check and now you can't go to G8
because the knights the uh if you go
King Jade Knight H6 is just mating once
you're gonna have to go back and now
once you go back Knight to G7 check
forces uh black to give up the queen or
you run away with the King but then just
Bishop to F5 with the check King to C6
and not just another beautiful four
carrier gonna win the Rook so of course
there's nothing for black to try here
but the radic went for Knights G7 with
check and now it really doesn't matter
King the f8 can be played now Knight
captures and E6 wins pretty much
everything and also you will get
checkmated and if you don't go there
yeah if you go King to D7 also doesn't
matter just Queen captures and F7 and
everything falls apart after King the
CID you could start grabbing material
but you could also just win the queen
and end the game that way so uh Magnus
tried it he tried the uh to be a little
bit funny playing the Polish opening
against the Polish Grandmaster against
number one polish Grandmaster Radice or
no he's not of course I believe dude of
course is number one uh so I I'm
guessing uh radic is number two but yeah
still still trying to be very funny uh
didn't work out this time and uh we're
gonna show a few more games and then
we're gonna discuss the standings after
the first game three rounds were played
and for those of you who are interested
who like to follow the live ratings
these are the live ratings for the uh
for the for the rapid you can see that
Magnus is no longer world number one in
Rapid Magnus is in fact number two he is
one point behind the classical world
champion dingler and who is 2830 and
Magnus is
28-29 so yeah for those of you who
joined that enjoyed that I hope you
enjoyed that as well uh so yeah thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I would
like to thank David Kimura MD recent
Enthusiast group golfsoftware.com Paul
hinamund and Gary Shaw for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and like I said I
will see you soon uh with more action
from the super bed rapid and Bliss but
we're also gonna continue covering other
events as there are so many events
happening right now so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day